hey, james murphy here with mCoding, in this
episode we're talking about positional-only
and keyword-only arguments in python. this is a
normal function definition with three arguments a,
b, and c. as is, we can pass any of the arguments
as either positional or keyword arguments.
here we pass them all as positional arguments,
and here we give all keyword arguments,
the order of the arguments doesn't
matter when we use keyword arguments,
and we can mix and match passing some parameters
as positional and some as keyword arguments.
you do have to pass all of your positional
arguments first though, so this is an error.
this gives callers of the function f a lot
of flexibility in how they want to call it,
but sometimes we don't want to give them all
that flexibility. and for those cases we can
actually require that certain arguments are
passed as positional arguments or require
that they're passed as keyword arguments. let's
see how syntactically you would make an argument
either positional- or keyword-only, and then,
more importantly, let's see why you would ever
want to do this. let's start with keyword only
arguments. inside your parameters, put a star.
the arguments before the star can still be
passed either as positional or keyword arguments.
things after the star now have to
be passed as keyword arguments,
or they could be omitted if they have
a default value. i guess, obviously,
if you try to pass a keyword argument as a
positional argument you get a syntax error.
we're going to have stars and slashes and star
stars and it might be a bit tricky to remember.
here's the way that you should remember that
everything after the star is a keyword argument.
recall what *args does *args eats
all remaining positional arguments.
in this case our positional arguments
are 1 and 2, which line up with a and b.
there aren't any more positional arguments
so args just becomes the empty tuple.
if we pass additional positional
arguments that's where they show up.
okay great, args swallows up anything
that's positional so... logically,
anything that comes after *args can't be
positional, otherwise it would have just been
part of args. so this is actually another way to
force an argument to be a keyword-only argument.
anything that comes after *args or *[whatever
variable name] must be a keyword-only argument.
that's how i remember that everything
after a star is keyword-only,
i'm just imagining it's short for *args
but i don't care about the args variable.
but, the plain star actually
has a benefit over using *args
unlike *args the plain star does not swallow
up all the rest of the positional arguments,
so this call where i have four positional
arguments is an error. whereas if i used *args
that 3 and 4 would just get swallowed up. this
can be a problem because it gives the accidental
opportunity to pass in something that you didn't
mean to. you could check to see if there were
any extraneous positional arguments that were
passed in and then raise an error if there are,
but that's just a lot of extra unnecessary work.
instead, just use a star and don't give it a name.
okay but why would you want a keyword-only
argument? keyword-only arguments are most
often used as options or settings that slightly
vary or modify the behavior of some code. this
"combined" function just takes two iterables and
then puts them one after another into a big list.
maybe we want to add some kind
of validation to this function.
if you passed in a callable validator then
we check that all the elements are valid.
we could just leave validator as a normal
argument, but then it's possible someone
sees a correct usage of this combine "sub"
and "scribe" and maybe they don't quite look
at the documentation... and they think that
they can just combine any number of things.
in this case we will get an error, but
it's not the one that i would hope we get.
the string ("!!") is taken as the validator, then
we'll get a crash when we try to use the string as
a callable object, which it's not. if the thing
that i tried to pass here happened to have a
similar enough interface to a validator, we might
have gotten the worst case: no errors at all,
a silent wrong answer. instead we use a star
and make validator a keyword-only argument.
now this caller will get the correct error, that
they passed too many positional arguments. you
can also use this to force your caller to spell
out exactly what argument they're passing in.
this can be useful if you really really want to
make sure that two arguments aren't mixed up.
you wouldn't want to mix up buying
10,000 of something at a price of 4,500 and
buying 4,500 of something at a price of 10,000.
using keyword arguments can minimize the
risk of this very plausible human error.
what about positional only arguments? here's
the syntax: in your argument list, put a slash.
there's no equivalent of *args for slash, this
is the only way you use it. any parameters before
the slash must be passed as positional, so it ends
up looking like this. positional arguments first,
then the slash, then normal arguments, they can be
passed either as positional or keyword arguments,
then a star, then keyword-only arguments.
you can even throw in **kwargs to catch all
remaining keyword arguments. i know this
notation is kind of annoying to remember.
i always start with the star. star is like
*args that eats all positional arguments.
anything to the right is keyword arguments, and
the things to the very left must be positional.
of course, you can mix and match all of these.
a slash directly followed by a star is a common
pattern to force all of the arguments to either
be positional-only or keyword-only. a slash at
the end means everything is positional. a star at
the beginning means everything is keyword-only.
but, the only way to really get the hang of it
is to just try a few. okay, now what are the
actual use cases for positional-only arguments?
consider this function "check_truthy". it checks
that the argument x is truthy and otherwise
raises an error. the context of this function
is incredibly general. it wouldn't be specific
to any particular domain or part of a program.
so why is its argument name x? well it's named x
because variables need names and i just picked x.
but x is not a meaningful name for this argument,
and i claim that there really is no meaningful
name. i mean, you could call it "object"
or something like that, but is that really
that meaningful? when you use this function just
pass in whatever you want to check is truthy.
this argument is best portrayed just
as the argument to the function,
it doesn't need and it shouldn't have a
name like x. so in this case we use the
slash at the end of the argument list to
force it to be a positional-only argument.
if i do this, then at some later time i'd be
free to change the name x to something else. for
instance, later i might want to decide that i want
to check any number of arguments for truthiness.
i can change x into *vals and then loop over
the x's because none of the people calling
this function referred to the variable x. this
is now a completely backwards compatible change.
another use case that i find often
comes up with positional arguments
is when the placement of the variables
mimics some kind of mathematical expression.
in this case i'm looking at raising x to
the y power and taking it mod some number.
in this case the names x and y don't really
convey which one is being raised to the other
power. it's more the fact that x comes first and
y comes second that x is being raised to the y.
and in this case i think actually specifying the
modulus this way makes it even more clear so,
to me, it makes sense to additionally
make mod a keyword-only argument.
what about all three? is there any case
where you really want positional-only,
positional- or keyword- and keyword-only? in
fact, there are zero examples of this in the
entire python standard library, with the exception
of the tests that this feature works. there are a
few cases though where you do this, where all of
the arguments are positional-only or keyword-only.
the best example i could find of this is actually
the dataclass decorator. dataclasses have tons of
different features that you can turn on and off,
so those make sense as keyword-only arguments,
but dataclass is a decorator so, by definition,
it takes a single callable as an argument.
so i guess yeah that makes sense. whatever it
applies to is the unique positional argument.
and finally let's do a speed test. are positional
arguments faster than keyword arguments?
and what if they're positional-only
or keyword-only arguments? how do the
timings of all of those compare? don't bother
reading all the code exactly, here's the setup.
i have a normal function with three regular
parameters, and i call it with positional,
keyword arguments, out of order keyword arguments,
and a mixture. then i redefine the function making
everything positional-only again, time that, then
redefine again and make everything keyword-only
and then time that in order and out of
order. then i just print out all the times.
and here are the timing results. all the numbers
are in nanoseconds so these are all really fast.
it's pretty clear there's a slight but
statistically significant difference.
we have 77 and 78, and any of the variations
that used any keyword arguments used at least
95 nanoseconds. so yes, positional arguments are
faster than keyword arguments. it didn't seem to
make any difference if they were positional-only
versus if you just happened to pass them as
positional. thank you all for listening, that's
all i've got. thank you to my patrons and donors
for supporting me. if you enjoy my content, please
consider becoming a patron on patreon. as always,
don't forget to subscribe and slap that like
button an odd number of times. see you next time